vous donnez d'abord votre nom, puis
vous décrivez plus tard d'accord, je m'appelle
Margot Berg et je suis la directrice artistique publique
du
bureau de la culture artistique dans l'
économie créative de la ville de Philadelphie et la pièce derrière moi
s'intitule gouvernement du peuple par le
l'artiste jacques lipchitz et il a été
créé en 1976 commandé par la ville
de Philadelphie à travers son pourcentage pour
notre programme et il représente il
représente vraiment la lutte pour la
démocratie il représente un groupe familial
et des corps fizza en quelque sorte empilés les uns sur
les autres au  tout en haut est
ce drapeau de Philadelphie qu'ils
tiennent en l'air, il représente donc la façon dont
chaque personne est impliquée dans la
création de la démocratie et que c'est une
lutte et quelque chose pour laquelle nous nous
battons tous les jours, donc à votre sens, ce qui
fait un petit regard  ton très spécial
bien sûr c'est l'art public qui
fait que tu es très spécial dans mon
esprit pourriez-vous Joseph j'ai commencé votre
phrase avec ce qui en fait un spécial  ok
ce qui rend Philadelphie spéciale pour moi, c'est
la collection vaste et variée d'
art public que nous avons dans tous les
quartiers de la ville, c'est dans tous
nos parcs et espaces civiques et c'est de
vous le savez une qualité merveilleuse très variée
avec des artistes représentant de  vous connaissez
les 18e 19e 20e et maintenant vingt et unième
siècles et vous connaissez
des artistes très renommés ainsi que
des artistes plus émergents et je pense que c'est
une fierté pour tous les
Philadelphiens merci
c'est bien je veux dire la seule chose que
j'ajouterais  est que je pense que ce n'est pas Rizzo
ne savait vraiment pas que Rizzo
ne voulait pas de cette couleur ici, il l'appelait
un tas de ressemblance à un tas de plâtre
que certains plâtres laissent tomber